how do you differentiate the fourth root
of x from first principles this is not
that hard if you remember how to
differentiate just the regular square
root of x from first principles you're
going to need to do some rationalizing
so to start this off what we should do
is we should remember the way that first
principles work so we'll let this
function equal F therefore what first
principle states is that f dash is given
by this particular function when you
take a limit on it namely f of X plus h
minus f of X all over H and what this
represents here this is a the regular
way that we've worked out gradient
it's rise over run but we're thinking
about the run as it gets increasingly
smaller so that's why you take the limit
as H approaches zero now in this case if
we make f the fourth root of x what
happens here well what I'm going to have
is this will be the derivative of the
fourth root of x ok everywhere I see and
if I'm going to put in the fourth root
of whatever that is there so have you
limit there it's very easy to forget you
limit don't do that you're going to have
the fourth root of x plus h minus the
fourth root of x all over H now this
looks hard to deal with but I can use
difference of squares
if I multiply here I can now try to
rationalize what's happening here so
what I would multiply by to take
advantage of difference of squares is
the conjugate of this numerator so that
would be the fourth root of x plus h
plus the fourth root of x ok now when I
multiply these two together difference
of squares is going to simplify it but
you can't just multiply it at the top
you've got to do the bottom as well
otherwise you've changed the fraction so
here we go multiplying by that over that
no change so what happens on the
numerator well write your limit in
because this is in the form a minus B a
plus B right that's what difference of
squares is I should get when I expand
these together I should get a squared
minus B squared that's what difference
of squares
but since my a is the fourth or
something MIB is the fourth or something
else a squared minus B squared will be
just the regular square root that minus
that that's my a squared and that's my B
squared right so if you can't quite see
that you know this fourth root of x plus
h you could rewrite that as X plus h to
the power of 1/4 right so if I square
this thing then I would square this
thing okay but the way the index laws
work is that you're going to multiply
those two powers they're 2 over 4 which
is 1/2 so that's why that's the square
root of x plus h which is what I have
here okay so that's what's happened to
the numerator what's happened to the
denominator or that original H is still
there and then you've got all of this
junk on the denominator which looks like
it'll be bad but if we stay with it it
should simplify out ok now my goal here
is to be able to get rid of this H in
the denominator because while it's in
the denominator I can't evaluate the
limit you can't stick zero into the
denominator because its division by zero
it doesn't work we don't know what that
means that's what the calculator says I
mean to insist undefined so in order to
do that I need to rationalize this
further I still had rationalize it I got
rid of the 4th roots but I've got square
roots so to do that I'll do the same
trick again I'm going to multiply by the
conjugate of the top that in this case
will be a square root of x plus h plus
the square root of x and of course I'm 5
multiply the top
I better multiply the bottom okay so
this is what I've got so now on the top
difference of squares again it's a minus
B a plus B so I'll get a squared minus B
squared here which is X plus h minus X
there's my a squared and there's my B
squared all over now you have this
really disgusting thing all on the
bottom you've got these two the two
fourth roots and then you've got these
two the square roots
okay now this doesn't look good but we
can work with it for instance on the
numerator you
got an X here nan - X there so that guy
and that guy I gotta cancel so all I
have is H now but if all I have is age
I've got an H on the numerator and the
denominator so that'll cancel with that
just leaves me one on the top now that's
really good because if I've got rid of
the H on the denominator which is what I
was trying to do before I can evaluate
this with H equals zero I can put H
equals zero into all of the places where
H is now so my next line doesn't have
limit anymore I'm actually going to say
now let's consider what happens when H
equals to zero I'll have the fourth root
of x plus zero there plus the fourth
root of x and then over here I'll have
the square root of x plus zero plus the
square root of x all right what does
that work out to be well 1 over this is
2 lots of the fourth root of x right
because that's the fourth root of x and
that's the fourth root of x we got two
of them
x to lots of the square root of x like
so okay now these are going to interact
with each other it's probably easier if
I put it into index notation I've got
two times two which is just four this is
X to the power of 1/4 and this is X to
the parallel our 1/2 so index law tells
me I should add these two numbers
together and I get 1 over 4 X to the
power of 3 over 4 ok right so there you
go that's that's how I went through it
my first principles I can check whether
I was right or not because I don't
actually I know how to deal with this
kind of function and how differentiate
it without first principles so all I
need to do is think about the fourth
root of x it is easier to think about it
as X to the power of a number because
they're really easy to differentiate and
it's just a quarter so when you
differentiate X to a number X raised to
a power
you bring that power at the front and
then you reduce the power by one 1/4
minus one is negative two recorders but
that negative that means this should be
on the denominator so this is actually 1
over 4x - 3 on 4 which is exactly what I
got before so that's how you do this by
first principles it's a bit longer
doing the square root of x because you
have to do this twice but it's exactly
the same kind of difficulty and you get
your answer at the end